- [Voiceover] Now let's apply the formula
we came up with the last video
sometimes known as the Einstein
velocity addition formula.
And we'll see that it's
a pretty neat thing.
So let's say, so this is once
again me floating in space,
my frame of reference is just
the s frame of reference,
Let's say my friend over here,
she's flying away from me, her velocity,
let's give it some numbers.
Let's say she's flying away from me
with a velocity of, let's say,
0.7c, so seven tenths
of the speed of light
or 70% of the speed of light.
And let's say this third
character right over here,
let's say they're flying towards me,
so let me change the
direction, the velocity vector.
So let me erase that.
Gee, that doesn't look like a pure black
but it looks fairly
erased, so there you go.
And let me give the velocity
vector in the other direction.
So the velocity vector,
this character is flying towards me
at let's say, so u is
going to be equal to,
so it's flying towards me
x is decreasing with time,
let's say it's negative,
- 0.5c,
so flying towards me at
half the speed of light.
And once again, both of these velocities
are given in my frame of reference.
Now if we were in a Newtonian world
or if we used the
Galilean transformations,
and this is released as
something on your highway.
If I'm on a highway and if
I'm going in one direction
at 70 miles an hour, and
someone is coming towards me
at 50 miles an hour, it'll look to me
like they are coming towards
me at 120 miles per hour.
We would essentially
add these two together.
And so, if we were in a Newtonian world,
this person is flying at 0.7c
and this person is
flying this way at 0.5c,
you would, in a Newtonian world, say okay
from this point of view it will look like
this blue character is approaching
at 0.7c plus 0.5c
or at 1.2 times the speed of light
which we know violates
the laws of the universe.
And that's where this
formula is really handy.
Actually let me even
make the spaceship point
in this direction just
so we don't get confused.
So the spaceship is going
in that direction just like that.
And once again, the
magnitude of the velocity
coming towards me is
half the speed of light.
I put the negative there to show
that it's coming towards me,
that x is decreasing over time.
Well, lucky for us in the
last video, we came up with
this Einstein velocity addition
formula, so let's apply it.
From this friend's frame of reference,
the s-prime frame of reference,
the velocity of this character
which is change in
x-prime over change in t
is going to be this.
So what do we have here?
So u is the blue velocity
in my frame of reference,
So that is -0.5c.
v is my friend's frame of reference,
the frame of reference
that we're trying to get the velocity in.
So that's 0.7c,
so let me do it in that color.
So that is 0.7c.
And then, on top of uv over c-squared,
so once again, u is
- 0.5c.
I know I wrote it really small.
And then, v is
0.7c.
So what is this going to be equal to?
Well, the numerator -0.5c
minus 0.7c,
that's going to be negative.
Our numerator, right over here
is going to be
- 1.2c.
And this is the velocity
that you would expect
if we were dealing in a Newtonian world.
This person says, "Hey, this person looks
"like they're coming towards me
"at 1.2 times the speed of light."
That's what our Galilean
transformations would give us.
But luckily, we have all
this business at the bottom
that keeps us from
violating the absoluteness
of the velocity of light,
this notion that nothing can travel faster
than the speed of light.
Because in our denominator,
we're going to get 1 minus 0.5c
times 0.7c.
Let's see, 0.5 times 0.7
is going to be 0.3.
So 0.3, I could say 0.30 if I liked,
but I'll just write 0.3c squared.
It'll be a negative.
I have a negative times a positive.
So I could put the negative there
but if I'm subtracting a negative,
that's just going to be a positive.
And I'm just going to divide by c-squared.
And so, that cancels out.
And so notice, we're going to be dividing
- 1.2c by something that's
slightly larger than 1.2.
So this is going to be
- 1.2c
over 1.3.
1.3
And so, lucky for us, this
is going to be less than c,
or this absolute value is
going to be less than c.
So it's going to be, let's
get a calculator out.
So, if we have
1.2 divided by 1.3,
this is equal to approximately 0.92.
So this is going to be approximately
- 0.92c
which is cool.
It kind of goes with our,
let me write it over here.
So this delta x prime over delta t prime
is -0.92c.
So it makes sense that from our
friend's frame of reference,
this ship will look like
it's approaching her
faster than from my frame of reference.
It looks like it's approaching
me in my frame of reference,
it looks like it's coming to
me at half the speed of light.
In her frame of reference,
it looks like it's coming at
0.92 times the speed of light.
The negative is just
specifying the direction.
But we didn't violate
the fundamental postulate
of special relativity,
that nothing can go faster
than the speed of light.
The speed of light is absolute.
So this is pretty cool.
I've often even thought about
making a video game somehow
where you leverage this,
where things are flying in
different relative velocities
but special relativity applies.